this piece of gear in front of me is
arguably the best sounding pair of
headphones ever made this is the Orpheus
from Sennheiser
it's not a new product it was originally
released in 1991 and at the time the
cost was twelve thousand five hundred
dollars only three hundred were ever
made they sold out immediately if you
wanted to buy one right now which you
probably couldn't but if you happen to
find one for sale on eBay or on the
second and audiophile market you can
expect to pay about twice as much and
really the whole reason this was built
was as an exhibit for headphones as art
the guys at Sennheiser wanted to prove
that they could build the best
headphones that they could and a lot of
the exotic materials and you see the
fancy wood the pretty finish all of that
has trickled down over the years as part
of company's DNA into the rest of its
products so if you look at what
Sennheiser is doing now you'll see hints
of what you see here showing up in its
modern products I also want to mention
that's not a typical headphone design
it's not cone drivers I could find in a
pair of headphones today they're
actually electrostatic headphones so
it's a very thin film of material and
electrical charges make it vibrate
everything is generated by the analog
class 8 amp that's inside the case one
other design feature that I want to
point out is if you look at the outside
of the case you'll notice there's no
on/off switch to turn it on you actually
have to insert a key and twist it just
like you're turning on a car so the idea
is that you have this in your home and
keep key on your key ring so that only
you can turn it on you know it's just
one of those little sort of high-end
things that makes it a little bit more
special than your average pair of
headphones
as if you couldn't tell just by looking
at it